[Music]
you've been busy were travel you were
just in Ireland I was in Ireland just a
couple weeks ago how was it it was
fantastic actually it's funny you bring
up Ireland you you came up I don't know
if your ears were burning
but I took a tour of the Guinness
Factory in Ireland and all I wanted was
the free Guinness right Nate insisted
that before I get the free Guinness that
I learn how Guinness is made the 175
steps mm-hmm and then I get to one part
and and they're telling me the different
people that have stopped by and well
let's take a look oh there's the Queen
Bill Clinton did Paul Rudd get free
Guinness I can't tell you that
information I'm Stephanie look at him
smiling that's a guy
[Applause]
I did get free Guinness but they do make
you take the tour they make you take the
tour and learn about where yeast comes
from huh barley and hops do you remember
a lot of what you learned
I remember the Guinness was good it's
true it's really good when you pour a
Guinness yeah you have to have it at the
right angle
yeah and then you leave you leave if you
fill it about 3/4 full yeah and then you
have to let it settle and the do you
remember the optimum time to let it
settle I remember it being about a
minute and a half or two minutes pretty
pretty close a minute and 19 and a half
seconds yes that's so serious they are
about it yeah and then when you finish a
Guinness if you're ever at a pub and you
see the guy kind of pull the tap to fill
up the last bit he's doing it wrong you
have to push it push it forward - yeah I
don't know - and if you do any of these
things wrong you're like oh yeah that's
right they're very angry leprechauns
serious about it look towards the
horizon arm up yes they told you when
you drink your Guinness you must look to
the horizon it all went dribbling down
my face
it's I dunno what the hell they were
talking about right